-Welcome back to "late night."
We're here with the fantastic
Ana Gasteyer.
Season 2 of any show
is exciting,
but this is such a good part.
Such a good clip earlier.
You play a bumbling CEO.
I feel as though we see those
in the news more and more.
It seems like a "delightly" --
delightfully, excuse me,
fun character to play.
-It is a delightly
-Delightly.
I think the way I said it
is right.
-Delightly.
-Yeah.
-It's delightly fun.
It is. It's amazing.
It's an ensemble cast.
It's a half-hour, you know,
workplace network comedy
in the great NBC tradition.
I mean, it's single-camera.
Justin Spitzer,
another Northwestern grad.
-Another Northwestern.
We're really shouting it out
a fair amount tonight,
but, you know, that's what
happens with excellence, yeah.
-[ Laughs ]
And, believe me,
they need the help.
-Hey, you have a very exciting
cameo coming up on Season 2.
-A little somebody to my left
might be appearing on the show
for a couple of episodes.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-This is very fun because --
-It's so fun.
-I don't think I have a ton
of range as an actor,
so I was very flattered
when you reached out
and asked if I wanted
to play myself.
[ Laughter ]
-No, it's pretty great
because we have so much --
So I play this, you know,
slightly in-over-her-head CEO,
as you mentioned.
First female CEO, big automotive
company, Payne Motors,
grand old venerable American,
you know,
manufacturing organization.
And I come in,
and I'm an experienced
and seasoned CEO
from Big Pharma,
but I don't know anything
about cars, and I don't drive.
-Yeah.
-And I'm of that school --
The character's of that school
of just like, "You don't need
to know the product.
You just got to know how to
sell it and manage people."
So she's very confident,
and it's just one calamity
after another.
She really -- It's a show of a
bunch of people on the C-suite
desperately trying to cover
their own asses, just like life.
-Yeah.
-And so she does -- she gets --
We ended last season with
kind of a huge PR crisis.
And her skill set was this kind
of super calm under pressure
due to all
the pharma experience.
And we came back at
the beginning of this season
with a biblical-level crisis,
and I become the most hated CEO
in the country,
and you get to make fun of me
on your show.
-And then you come as a guest
on my show.
-I do.
-And I'm very excited to see it.
And that's I think
in a couple of weeks.
-Yes, it is.
I think it's Episode 2.
-We have worked together
over the years,
but we only overlapped
one year together on "SNL."
And then you threw me
many bones,
because this was
a time in my life
where I was just happy
to be in anything, right?
Season one on "SNL,"
you will take any part.
You played a character
named Sarah Blazen
and were very kind
to let me be a backup dancer,
which, by the way,
was probably the only thing
I did in the show that week,
so that is --
-No, but I have
such a fond memory.
Okay, so this is one
of those sketches.
I did it twice.
This was my --
This, I think,
was the first time.
Another James Anderson
spectacular.
-Yeah.
-She was an old Broadway dame.
She would come in if
Carol Channing was hit by a bus
or something like that.
-Yeah.
-You know, Leslie Uggams,
something terrible
would befall her,
and they would bring in Blazen
at the last --
But she had a lot of issues.
She had a pin in her hip,
so she would not do any
of the choreography.
Do you remember that?
And she would keep
referring to it.
They would say, like,
"Hey, what if you get up
and you do a jazz square?"
♪ I got a pin in my hip ♪
Yeah, so, um, she was --
she was -- she was very sassy.
Thank you.
She was very sassy.
And I'll never forget you --
I have such a clear, like,
feeling of joy
that you loved the character
at the rewrite table,
because I remember
she would bitch and moan
and make all these people,
like, serve her
and bring the key
down really low
'cause she'd smoked and drank
her whole life.
And then at, like, the 11th
hour, she would just quit.
-Yeah, right before it started,
she would quit.
She would make you
meet everything.
-And I remember
that you loved that.
-And here is --
This was another "SNL" host
that I think not a lot of people
remember, Jonny Moseley.
-Yeah, skier Jonny Moseley.
-Skier Jonny Moseley.
Like, trick skier.
I feel like he had
a move called...
-What was it?
-...Jelly Roll, maybe?
-It involved some--
-It was spinning in the air
on skis.
We're not making this up.
-The Dinner Roll. Google it.
-I know we're
very good improvisers.
You might be like,
"Oh, they're doing a bit."
-It was called the Dinner Roll.
I don't know.
-I should note, I do want
to stress, lovely guy.
I enjoyed the week a great deal.
-So nice.
-This is a very unfair photo,
'cause it seems like
I'm jealous right now.
-And also, I mean,
he put on a dance tight.
-Yeah, he put on a dance tight.
-You go, Jonny Moseley.
-You medaled for me.
I'm very excited about this.
You did a wonderful parody
of the sort of
Hallmark Christmas movies
or Christmas movies in general.
-No, Hallmark,
very specifically.
-I feel like last time
when I said Hallmark,
you guys said, "Whaa."
-It was probably
just 'cause Viacom
didn't want us to say that.
-Okay. Gotcha.
So now the truth is out.
And it was you
and Rachel Dratch.
And it was
"A Clusterfunke Christmas."
And these are -- I mean, there's
like an industrial complex
of Christmas movies.
-This is right.
-And they have some
really wonderful tropes
that recur often.
-They're all the same movie.
They're all a very uptight,
bitchy executive
goes usually to a small town
at Christmas,
and she wants to buy the inn
and destroy it
and turn it into a parking
complex and, I don't know,
indoor water ski facility.
-Yeah.
-And she doesn't
believe in Christmas.
Of course she hates Christmas,
and she hates love.
So she comes to the small town
and then miraculously meets
a non-January-6th-participating
lumberjack, and...
it's amazing.
And she -- And she --
He takes her into
his be-flanneled arms.
And she --
And also the other thing
I love about these movies,
they have one date, and then
she gives up her entire career.
Usually, like, you know,
Harvard law.
She's like, "Screw it.
I'm staying at the inn."
-Yeah, and it's like a for sure
all-the-clothes-stay-on romance.
Like, you know what I mean?
One date where it's like
they maybe kiss on the cheek
after a cocoa.
-So there really are --
We produced it with our friend
Danielle von Zerneck,
who has produced a lot
of actual Hallmark movies.
And so we wanted -- as I'm sure
in your "Documentary Now!"
division --
-Right, you want accuracy.
-Absolutely picture --
There's Christmas
in every frame.
There's all these rules.
Like there's a --
There was a plaid ban
for a long time at Hallmark.
So when we went
to start costuming,
the costumer,
completely seriously, said,
"Now, are we honoring
the plaid ban?"
-Now, what brought --
-I don't know.
Some exec had a real beef
with plaid.
I don't know if something just
was a trigger area for that --
Yeah, so Dratch and I play
these old innkeepers who,
again, look at the picture,
are in their 40s.
But in these movies --
in these movies,
you're either a breeder
or an old prune.
So we were not the breeder.
The lovely Vella Lovell was.
But we --
So we're writing a sequel.
-You're writing a sequel,
and this one is now visiting
one of the new tropes.
-We are -- The area this time
is a royal holiday.
-A royal holiday, because there
is -- I will say, a lot of them
seem to have "prince"
or "princess" in the title.
-Yes, there's another
whole trope
where you either didn't know
you were royalty
or you secretly become a nanny
and the prince
falls in love with you.
-Yeah.
-There's a lot of --
So the premise at the moment
is that we go
to an international
strudel competition in --
'cause we're
world-renowned strudelers.
-Yeah.
-And the -- And two princes,
for reasons not clear to us,
fall in love with us.
[ Laughter ]
-Well, I cannot wait for that.
-Thank you.
-And I can't wait for
"American Auto" to come back.
You guys, that's Ana Gasteyer.
-Thank you.
-Her show "American Auto" --
Tuesday nights, 8:30,
here on NBC.
We'll be right back
with Bomani Jones.